And of course code snippet 2 represents a gather
since each thread is going to access 3 elements of the N array
and then do some math and store the results into a single place in the output array,
and that gather operation is going to run much faster, right?
You probably noticed that in fact the first operation is accessing more memory
since it has to read the 3 output locations in order to increment them,
and it won't even run correctly unless we insert some sink threads barrier in here
or use atomic operations to guarantee that 1 thread doesn't read a value
while another one is in process of updating it.
Either of those would further reduce performance, and this is typical,
A gather pattern results in many overlapping reads
that the hardware can typically handle more efficiently
than it can handle many potentially conflicting writes, which is what you tend to get from this scatter pattern.
So now if the pattern of reads can't be determined ahead of time,
you may need to combine this with Stratten's technique number 5, binning.
We'll come back to that.